blad Smiths welcome to the forge in this
first round of competition you're going
to have to forge your signature blades
from this
material Salvage steel we've got bicycle
chain chainsaw chain cable wire spud
wrench lawnmower blade railroad spike
fer file and Jackhammer bits you must
also include a visual element from
whatever steel you choose into your
Blaze design in an order chosen at
random before you entered the forge you
will now come forward and choose one of
the steals each item can only be
selected by one
contestant Ryan you're up first please
choose your steel I have free rain over
anything on that
table I choose the Jackhammer bits
because in terms of edge retention they
take a lot of abuse and I don't think I
have anything to worry about in terms of
heat treating it Mark you're up
next Steve you're last choose your
Steel I was hoping for cable even though
cable is very difficult to work with
I've used it before so at least I got a
shot you will have 10 minutes to work on
your designs you will have 3 hours to
forge your blades good luck blad Smiths
your 10-minute design window starts now
I'm designing a recurve bolo style blade
because the bolo design a little bit
heavy on the front end for a chopping
that's tapered back into a nice thin
cutting knife I've recently completed my
journey and blad rating I feel a lot
more comfortable in my skills that's all
the stamp they just give you the stamp
and right away you you have the
skills I think my biggest strength in
Blade making is my knowledge of
historical blades so I'm designing a
straight up broad saxs the rasp is
probably the most simple thing to keep
the element in the blade I don't get
nervous about things very often um I
think the thing that made me the most
nervous was losing my
voice I'm going to make make a drop
point recurve blade I am an artist and
the advantage I think I might have is my
artistic ability and being able to see
clean lines and make a really beautiful
blade growing up I was told that you
shouldn't be an artist and I would make
myself prove to them that they're wrong
your 10-minute design window is closed
your 3-hour Forge time starts now it's
very nice to see Steve is welding the
ends of his cable cuz we seen what
happens when you don't it'll just
unspool and come apart in pieces working
with cable can be difficult but it was
smart to pick it cuz if he Forge WS it
correctly he'll have a very tough
material a piece of cable this large
takes more effort and more time to get
Forge welded up successfully cable is
dirty nasty stuff to get a good weld it
needs to be clean I can add a little
flux I can wire brush it and then start
tightening it and just start working on
that weld if I don't get it welded up I
don't have a knife at the end it's it's
that
simple so Steve's got his Billet over on
big blue and it looks like it's holding
together from here I'm confident that I
have completed the most important part
of this task the forge weld now I have a
working piece that I can continue my
drawing
process I clean up my blade and make it
look all pretty and I've Incorporated
the knob part of the Jackhammer bit
inside of the blade Tang Junction he
quenched it in water I don't know what's
happening he didn't dip in water he was
just screwing with us he's teasing us
he's teasing us he just wanted to see my
head pop yeah it is very nice to know
the judges were paying
attention BRX has a spear tip point so I
do a Japanese tip cut Mark he's got a
very very lean blade and those FS wraps
around it at the end it's very easy to
draw a tip out of that instead he cut a
preform so he's lost even more material
so when he gets to the grinder he likely
won't have much material left I would
venture to say that Mark's forging on
that was the absolute minimum he could
possibly do yeah and without reforging
that metal entirely you won't know
exactly how strong it
is Steve just quenched my question to
you is what does Steve have to do to
make sure that we see cable on his blade
you can take a piece of that cable wrap
around a rasso or something like that to
ensure the fact that it is a knife made
from cable I add cable
bolsters now there is no doubt that this
knife is
capable look at Ryan showing a lot of
patients he's doing thermal cycling so
that's
good we've got Ryan there in
quench I file test it and realized iiz
only the top third of my blade is
Harden I'm going to have to take a
chance and quench again and pray that
this thing hardens up pretty
good the quench is the most important
aspect of making a blade because before
that it's nothing but a piece of metal
and I'll test it first time quench is
good 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 blad Smith
shut down your machines return your an
bills your work is
done Smiths welcome to the strength test
the ice block
chop I'm going to take each of your
knives and strike these ice blocks six
times this is going to test the strength
of your Edge as well as the overall
durability of your knife Steve you're up
first are you ready yes
let's do
[Music]
it head just perfect didn't roll over
didn't chip out the handle is a little
bit narrow but uh it held up good job
thank you Ryan you ready do I have a
choice no not really all
yours good
God held up Ryan still got a really
really sharp edge on there my concern is
the handle having this integral chunk
here immediately just want to reach up
and grab it up here that's not where you
want it cuz you don't want so close to
the edge there
Mark what you thinking I'm ready to
[Music]
rock marks you held up you got a little
bit of edge deformation there's nothing
major there's definitely some issues on
the handle I mean you've got a guard on
here but it's not all the way up that's
why it's nice to have a rasso here so it
makes it easier to fit the guard up
without all this gapping
here next up is a sharpness test for
that I'm going to turn you over to
Doug that was fun to watch your blades
go up against the ice but are they still
sharp I will take your weapon and I'll
deliver three slices on this rope Steve
you're up first you ready let's do
this
all right St it wouldn't cut all the way
through the Rope but it is sharp enough
to lacerate some of the strands so
overall your knife will cut thank you
Ryan you're next you ready all yours
buddy
[Music]
well I don't see any deformations on the
blade it stayed true it did slice some
pieces of the Rope so it is sharp and
your blade will cut thank you sir Mark
you're up you ready let's do
it
nice your edge
geometry definitely works better on a
rope cut it's sliced in deeper overall
your blade will cut thank you but on
your handle construction there's a lot
of gaps I can see you can see the glue
all over so it's not as finished as the
other blades and it's only held together
by Glue regardless of my handle I'm
thinking I'm running even simply because
my test performance were better than the
other
contestants blade Smiths it's time for
one of you to leave the
forge Mark your blade did not make the
cut Jay neelen will explain Mark aside
from being the only blade to suffer
damage during our testing we also felt
that your blade was the least finished
of the three so for those reasons we
have to let you go Mark please surrender
your
blade my blade was not as finished as it
should be yeah I tried right to the last
second but I ran out of time I may not
be a fortune fire Champion but I'm
definitely the quietest Fortune fire
[Music]
competitor